hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about axial filament
specifically axial filament is found in
bacteria known as spirochetes
and so these are different from the
axial filaments that are found in sperm
cells or for instance so let's get
started an axial filament is used for
movement so its function is in motility
the way it works is it is this long
structure that's shown here in purple
that actually rotates relative to the
cell body so here we've got the cell in
black and we've got the axial filament
in purple and so the axial filament
excuse me the axial filament will rotate
sort of around the cell body and that's
what leads to to this movement and so
it's composed of these structures known
as endo flagella and it causes a sort of
rotating twisting corkscrew type
movement it's found in bacteria known as
spirochetes some examples of spirochetes
are Treponema pallidum which causes
syphilis as well as Borrelia burgdorferi
which causes Lyme disease
now they originate at the poles of the
cells the poles may in the ends and
that's what's shown here the axial
filament starts at one end and then
wraps around the cell towards the other
end and that they're located in a
portion of the cell known as the
periplasmic space so what does that mean
peri plasmic space is the space and
gram-negative bacteria that is between
the inner membrane and the outer
membrane so here's what that looks like
we have first inside the cell we have
the cytoplasm the cytoplasm is where the
bacterial chromosome will be where its
liposomes are or inclusion bodies are
delirious sort of cytoplasm contents and
then right here we have the inner
membrane and so the inner membrane
surrounds everything in the B cytoplasm
and then outside of that interval brain
there's what's known as the outer
membrane which is right here now between
the inner membrane and the outer
membrane there is some space it's known
as the periplasmic space
and that is where the end of flagella
that make up the axial filaments are
found
so right here we are looking at a
cross-section of the cell I probably
should have said that to begin with so a
cross-section of a cell like this and so
here are all of those endo flagella that
make up the axial filament so the axial
filament is this portion right here so
axial filament is made up mini endo
flagella they sort of twist around the
cell to cause this twisting corkscrew
like motion that we associate with the
spire heats that have these axial
filament so that is it for today if
you're interested in learning some more
about bacterial movement check out my
video on the different arrangements of
flagella which are those extracellular
appendages that were maybe more familiar
with that more bacteria have if you're
interested in learning a little bit more
about gram positive versus gram-negative
cell walls this being an example of a
gram-negative cell wall then please
check out my video on gram-positive and
gram-negative cell walls and thanks for
watching biology professor